Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day they come in,
they weigh in.
Then once we record it,
make sure they're cool,
they can rehydrate and they have many,
many more hours to rehydrate.
So guys,
we're rehydrating six hours earlier.
Most guys showed up at 10:00 AM they made weight and then they had way more
time.
So when you saw people stand on the scale,
I was saying official weight,
when I was announcing it,
they had weighed in at 10 o'clock in the morning.
So it was already four in the afternoon.
These guys were hydrated and thick.
No one looks sick,
at least visually.
No one looked like,
like Conor McGregor looked when he fought Chad Mendez when they weighed in and
he looked like a dead man.
A dead man.
S cheeks were all sucked in.
It looks horrible.
I mean,
look,
you did good in the fight.
Yeah,
but uh,
he really did.
He cuts a lot to get to one 45.
He's a big boy.
He's way bigger than,
um,
like chosen.
Aldo and Josie all was cutting a lot at one point.
His career.
Oh,
by the way,
I've never a hardcore fan.
I've never enjoyed the fight more than I enjoyed Nate Diaz.
Conor Mcgregor,
I was lost my mind so much at the end of the fight.
I mean,
I'm a huge Diaz Fan and that was just incredible.
on 10 days notice.
Yup.
Well that whole,
um,
to card or that to fight,
event,
the two fights,
uh,
the final fights,
the Holly Holm,
Miesha Tate was one of the most exciting endings to any fight ever.
When Misha took Holly down in the fifth round of fight where she was losing it,
took her back and choked her.
That's insane.
I read an article today where someone was saying that it was,
that me,
she had lost virtually every second.
It was from a guy I respect a writer and she won the second.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
The second round,
she took her down and pounded her.
I think they did they give her a 10,
eight yes.
And they should,
she dominated.
So I read this article,
this is ESPN writer wrote it and I was like,
wait a minute man,
come on.
You can't say that like,
why are you saying that?
Like that's,
that's silly hyperbole,
right?
It doesn't even make any sense.
Um,
and me show it was threatening in the third and fourth after that,
Holly was on her bike.
She was like,
fuck this.
Like she's fighting perfect and super cautious with no chances and barely
winning those rounds,
you know,
just winning them but barely winning.
He wasn't nothing,
nothing big happened and definitely no threat.
So that victory when Misha Tate choked out,
Holly and Holly's punching in the air,
like how fucking dramatic is that going out cold punching in the air while she's
going out.
And then Nate beating up Connor and that second round after he gets fucked up in
the first round,
beating him up in the second round and then choking him insane.
Probably like two,
two of the most exciting finishes to any fight ever.
And the,
and the Connor thing was just insane because he was on a tear that was one of
the biggest tears in MMA history.
And uh,
to watch it go down like that,
especially like you said,
like he was winning the fight and then Nate turns it around and it was almost
like on a drop of a dime,
like nay,
nay,
like came to life in that second round and starts talking shit.
So it was really fun in a home for the Jab.
He hit him with that big one too and it was like,
oh well they has a snake,
like one to two.
He like whap whap and then he liked slithers around.
You can't find them with the counter.
He's really good.
And there's no one worse than a Nate or Nick Diaz to get hurt by in a fight
because once they hurt you,
they just like,
they push a pace and then when you get hurt they like pick it up and pick it up.
And then all of a sudden,
I mean before you know it,
Conner's hit like 25 fucking times on the feet and he's shooting for a take
down.
Those guys are always doing triathlons.
So even though Nate is like you're taking that fight in 11 days notice and he
wasn't in shape,
he's still in way better shape than most people.
So like him going five rounds is non feasible.
It's not,
it's not outside of the realm of imagination.
He's in shape.
He's just not in the kind of shape that he's going to be when they have a
rematch.
And that becomes a real fucking problem.
Cause I think he's going to beat him up again with Nate sad.
He's like goes,
he goes,
I have,
if I had a camp we wouldn't have fucking touch me.
He goes,
my plan was to go out slow in the first round and he came out fast enough in the
first round.
So I got tagged a couple of times.
But that's so cool.
That's cool.
Stick to the plan,
stick to the plan.
And then the second round it starts loosening up and opening up.
And Conor was just dead.
Yeah.
Well I heard,
I mean people are talking to Nate about,
cause you know,
going into that fight,
like Connor's power,
it was what a lot of people were talking about.
Like,
you know,
he put one punch on Josie Aldos Chin and he's out and he's talking,
he's like,
they can't handle it.
My power,
I don't do us as well.
But uh,
but uh,
and Nate was saying in one of the post fight interviews where it was like,
look,
I'm spoiling with Andre Ward and Joe Schilling and like heavyweight boxers.
I'm doing rounds with heavyweight boxers.
There's nothing you're going to hit him with that he hasn't seen or kind of
dealt with when he's,
I mean,
you know,
like talking like Andre Ward and Joe Schilling,
like decent strike.
You're saying literally the best,
the best,
the best inboxing and the best of the kickboxing.
Well,
Joe Schilling cuts wait to kickbox at 185 pounds and knocks dude's dead dead
with one punch.
So that guy is sparring with Nate on a regular basis.
Andre Ward,
who is one of the best fucking boxers on the planet earth.
One of the slickest said that Nate gives as good as it gets when they spell.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And I think Joe Schilling,
I might be getting it,
but I think Joe Schilling said he's never heard either one of them and a
sparring session.
I think he said that on a fighter and the kid,
I believe it man.
Tough fucking dudes,
man.
Tough fucking dudes.
But what's fascinating to me is that he wanted to jump right back in there and
do it again and that Nate wanted to,
or that I'm Connor wanted to just run it back and I was like,
wow,
that's interesting.
It seems weird that he gets to do that.
Not so much that he wants to,
but it just seems weird that they were like,
uh,
like even when Dana White was talking about in his like,
look man,
we tried to convince them to go down to one 45.
And he was like,
Nate's the,
I was like,
wait,
he's the matchmaker now.
He just gets to go.
Wouldn't you let them if you want,
if you want to make a ton of money,
right?
Man,
I believe in the market and that guy's,
that guy's what people want to see.
He can do what he can do,
whatever he wants to do.
But Nate's going to get a big pay day off it.
But it's not just that the emperor has been stripped down.
Okay.
So now he's exposed.
So now someone's beating him.
So here's the thing,
what do you do now?
You want to make money.
Okay.
Cause if you want to make money,
you make the biggest fight you can right now while he's been exposed.
And the biggest fight for sure is when I say expose,
I don't mean he's not talented.
I mean exposed,
meaning he's a human and he can lose.
And that happens with every fighter they lose.
And once they lose,
people go,
oh,
you can be beat.
You know,
we saw it with Anderson Silva,
you saw with Mike Tyson and when after Mike Tyson fought buster Douglas,
who was a different world,
there were,
everybody was like,
oh he's human.
So I say exposed not in a disrespectful way,
but got exposed.
He lost,
he got choked out.
I got beaten up on the ground and then he got choked out quick.
So this is not an invulnerable,
perfect fighter who's unbelievably durable,
right?
Who can take punishment like no man.
There's a lot of those guys in the UFC,
there's champions like that in the UFC that are like Robbie Lawler.
Unbelievably durable.
You can't put them away.
It's fucking hard to put that guy away.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about a guy got dinged up,
shot for a Shitty,
wide open takedown,
got taken down and got demolished on the ground and got choked unconscious
quickly afterwards.
So,
all right.
What do you do?
Could that happen with dos Anjos fuck yet.
Could Dosantos could do that too?
It's possible.
I mean condom might knock 'em out.
You never know.
Kind of does have that punch,
but you got to put him in against Nate again cause that's the big money rematch.
And if,
if this guy turns out to be a guy who's going to win some and lose some and the
beginning of his career,
this unbeatable wild Celtic warrior character.
Oh that's all gone.
But he's champ.
He's still got a belt at one 45 yeah.
So it's almost kind of a,
a weird position for now.
But I mean,
here's my question.
When I say for now,
can you really keep banking that weight?
That's what I'm saying.
Well I've wondered about that too.
I've heard some people have argued with me saying like,
no,
he can make the weight.
Cause he was,
he was what it was.
He won 69 against Nate.
So they're saying he basically,
that's what he starts at and he can just cut down from there.
That's a lot.
But look what he looked like at the,
at the way in.
So maybe you can,
I mean he kinda,
he definitely can do it.
It's physically possible.
I was so looking forward to the press conference though,
just because I can't,
you know,
you've got this guy in Connor who is like the ultimate shit talker.
And then you've got Nate,
who,
I mean,
the first,
the dynamic at the first press conference was amazing.
It was amazing.
And at that moment when he was just like kind of talking circles around Nate and
they just broke and he goes,
how about this?
Fuck you.
Fuck your belt.
Fuck this press conference.
Like they just went to gangster on them.
But now like how can con I was so interested,
like how can he show up and talk shit like that when Nate's got the perfect
rebuttal that anything he has to say 10 days,
just saying all kinds of crazy stuff.
Like the first eight minutes were easy.
Well,
yeah,
but here's the difference between the first day,
the last three minutes,
the last three were a lot worse.
Yeah,
they were awful.
Like you got fucked up,
man.
Do you got to just accept that?
But that's part of his thing is that he has to like look at things in the most
positive light possible.
And Man,
I dunno.
Um,
I think stylistically it's a troublesome fight for him because Nate is a very
clever boxer and his ground game is a world from where Connor is right now.
And I've seen Nate role with guys.
He's a fucking legit,
very high level Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt under a very respected camp.
His cardio is outstanding.
His boxing's nasty.
So where's Connor's shining?
The only way I think,
I mean,
I guess there's like,
you know,
it's,
it's really hard to like fight a Diaz brother and beat them.
You're usually when people beat them,
it's kind of like their,
they really stick to a strategy.
You've got to kind of take them down and avoid submissions or like leg kick and
circle on Joe's.
Beat him up in that way.
But you know what,
there's also different show up.
Well,
there's also,
you know,
different camps.
You know,
you're coming in,
who knows what kind of fucking injuries you're dealing with.
You know,
you've,
you see a guy like Nate come in and look really kind of lackadaisical against
Hofeld dos Anjos.
Then you see him come back and look shredded against Michael Johnson and looks
sensational.
So you go,
okay,
that's what he's capable of when he's on and focus,
you gotta be ready for that guy.
And I think that,
yeah,
that's the best he's ever looked at.
You got Michael Johnson fight.
You can't think that the guy who lost dos Anjos is showing up.
You've got to think of the guy that came out,
swarmed cowboy in the first round is common.
Like that guy's a clever fucking boxer.
So where does Connor shine?
Knock out power.
That's where he shines.
Like Connor can dead dudes.
Yeah.
They're tough to hit.
They have great head movement and Green Chins and they there,
they roll with punches.
Well,
the only guy to ever stopped Nate was,
um,
Josh Thompson and Josh did.
It was a brutal head kick.
And Josh Thompson to this day,
I say it's one of the most underrated guys.
He just,
he,
it,
the stars did not align for him,
but he could have easily been a UFC champion.
He was champion a Strikeforce.
Yeah.
And with Gilbert and him and Gilbert went back and forth,
you know,
Josh Thompson's worldclass fighters.
So when Josh Thompson head kicked him,
you know,
it's like Josh to do that to anybody in that division and then it catches you.
You know,
you're fucked.
He sees an older now and he's just know,
I think he's a guy that like,
like I said,
the stars didn't like perfectly aligned for,
but like skill wise and technique wise,
he's a fucking world class fighter.
So when he knocked out Nate Diaz,
it's not necessarily an indication that Nate Diaz is done,
but he's just,
you know,
that's how good Josh Thompson is.
Yeah.
And at the time,
and then,
so Nate rebounds from that.
And I think people you look at like the losses is like the dos Anjos fight.
And you look at that,
the Josh Thomson fight,
and you go,
well,
how good is he?
You know,
I can beat that guy.
But then you look at the Michael Johnson finding go,
Woo that that guy is fucking dangerous.
Jim Miller.
Serone exactly.
Lot of these fights where was just unbelievable.
Uh,
and I think,
uh,
it's,
it's one of those things were styles,
make fights and,
you know,
kind of really gotten people's heads by talking shit.
And I felt like going in,
I was like,
I don't think you're going to get in Nate's head.
My talking shit.
He's not that guy.
Yeah.
How about this micro fuck up your whole crew gangster thing you could say,
by the way,
that's the most gangster thing.
Cause he's literally just going,
we'll fucking jump you dude.
Like we're not like,
we're not playing around here.
And all those guys,
even the guys who seem like kind of Nice guys in his team,
like Jake shields,
you feel like he'll fucking jump.
You guys are vegetarian and it'll kick your ass.
Yeah.